let's suppose you actually do get that
okay great
your to show up on this lot at this time
what does someone need to prepare what
are some of the things that just seems
so minuscule that you wouldn't think are
important that are actually very
important that PE whether it's body
language whatever it is mean to pet you
pitch you want to you have to know how
to read a room okay you have to
something that I I know this sounds
really idiotic but I think it works is
you take a post-it right and a big fat
sharpie you know like a magic marker or
whatever you call this you know with the
thick and if you can't write your pitch
out on that little post-it dump oh
really
okay because they if you can't write it
that quick then it's not gonna be a
clean concept and they don't want
character movies because I'm gonna take
me don't want them they want good
character but they don't want movies
that are reliant well right now they
don't want anything except pits of the
economy but even when they were open to
smaller movies you can't go pitch a
character movie because then it's
entirely dependent upon the execution
but if there's a concept there that they
love they'll go give this writer a shot
he's cheap you know cuz if he's a new
writer he scaled right maybe plus ten
but but we love the concept so we'll
give them a shot but if it doesn't work
we can put a writer on because we like a
seasoned writer because we love the
concept but if the kid comes in in
pictures a character thing then you know
there's there's no they're there to
replace him with you know because if if
you know like there are character movies
that are like you know ordinary people
just popped in my mind brilliant you
know it took those elements to make that
work to to get it made you know you
couldn't go and pitch that even then I
don't think if you were a new writer
you